[Musique]
afin de varier le menu de nous armer qdt
julien faubert achi à tirage phrase à
bord nous prépare des brochettes
original et là on va faire du poisson
s'agit pas de simples que vous venez de
badigeonner d'huile
je lève pas gêner encore plus juste pour
ça et même un peu plus juste pour ça pas
que le bois y brûle unique immédiatement
alors nous qu'est-ce qu'on fait aux
médecins sur le barbecue
le bois ça aide à rebaptiser la viande
et de bain sacré justement une zone de
protection pour que la peau de cole pop
on vient faire un petit lit ici d'herbe
d'agrumes la planche est recouverte
d'estragon des nets et de coriandre
on y dépose aussi du citron et de
l'aliment tranche la bonne façon juste
m je sans filet je sais faire un stylet
ça se passe à 1 pour tout le monde non
plus là alors on va les recevoir si bien
des arêtes moi ça me dérange pas les
arrête parce que je me sois crir les
êtres face à la cuisson vont lever alors
c'est plus facile à enlever
on enfile brochettes à la japonaise
comme si on faisait une couture on
saupoudre avec un mélange de poivre et
de zestes de citron avant de déposer sur
le lit d'aromates mais déjà ça c'est
magnifique c'est beau c'est bon aussi
pour les invités cra qui voit sol
parfums les humbles bois qui brûle qui
sont comme ça c'est une excellente qu'on
fait parce qu'on veut que le poisson et
le temps de bien créer non brûlés et que
trop bête pourrait refuser le poisson de
tous les parfums qui se dégage la
cuisson est faite à l'étouffée alors
voilà notre base européenne sur le bois
de s'être excision landes cuisson
la salle agneau aux épices de la route
de la soie sur sa propre brochette rendu
brèche est là qu'est ce qu'on va faire
après le mans va jusque là ce n'est que
du soleil et on va utiliser de mortier
pour faire pour créer notre porte
on était gras de l'ail du sel du zeste
de l'hymne de la citronnelle et du gala
nga une épice qui s'apparente au
gingembre le tout coupé grossièrement et
non plus si je commence à toute plaie je
peux avoir quelque chose qui est très
très robuste j'ai besoin quelque chose
de très robuste pour faire une marinade
parce que ça va m'arriver au moins 24
heures alors vous me suces mettre un
petit peu de crimes en deuil et on va
mettre des olives ordonnée nonne acidité
de nouveaux arrivants et du tamarin qui
est là mais vu lone star est frais le
fonds a par le passé par tout le monde
qui connaît le dogme auquel ce n'est pas
toujours évident à trouver quand sa
frayeur mais on peut trouver dans toutes
les épiceries asiatiques ou africaines
encore tout ce qu'on fait en fait on
fait jusqu aux os et la coke et ça goûte
entre le fig et on enlève les cales
il est noyau afin de retirer la pâte qui
se retrouve à l'intérieur on peut aussi
se procurer une patte de tamarin déjà
pris paris dans les marchés spécialisés
jamais une karine là dedans que ça va
aider aussi le parfum de
pour l'agneau alors on remet dame entier
en fait tout le frapper tout doucement
ok alors qu'on pensait alors ont montré
comme un oeuf belle porte et on va
acheter l'huile juste pour ramener tout
son sens on enduit la new de cette pâte
qu'on laisse mariner pendant 24 heures
avant de griller à feu vif avec la
chaleur ne faut pas avoir peur d'y aller
avec ses mains alors on sent déjà
l'odeur les épices
dès que ça touche et le feu de la pente
a déjà commencé avec à se marier avec de
l'animal et surtout avait des invités
tout le monde se rassemble autour du
barbecue 500 donc vous voyez déjà la
coloration elle est belle on tourne on
vient 16 est vraiment rapidement les
faces c'est sûr que sur lesquelles on va
voir les aspects plus marquer mais on
veut vraiment avoir l'aspect à caramel
un peu en bray de la protéine haut
niveau ici on voit les gros je vais
venir poser sur le groupe pour qu'il est
gros plus bien tombé vous voyez il ya
des petites bulles de sang ici si vous
voulez prêt soit médium saignant vous
laisser le s'en sortir un peu comme ça
reposer et vous avez su leur tournée du
côté de l'os pour finir la cuisson et
c'est très important de faire reposer la
viande après après avoir sorti du guil
on laisse reposer au moins deux minutes
pour que les jus y restent en place
ça c'est là qu'ils sont en parfaite
voilà nos côtes d'agneau la façon la
faute de la soie alors laissé près de
déguster oui j'suis pas bon c'est
tellement pas semblant